ok catch a voice aika yeah we're gonna
do there were a young yet ok and you
know it's got got my main man kanye west
right here and we got this you got this
browse okay so let's do it get the [ __ ]
out of the way isn't she being a cage
for something oh you better hide that
before I milk it that's all I gotta sent
you that I hide it before I'm not get it
has this [ __ ] that will milk that thing
until it is bone dry that's all i gotta
say i'm trying that way and i like you
say like when i see just tits on
anything a doorknob a box I just milk it
immediately like I you know the teething
techniques you know with the tape so you
don't like her dumb but you get the
maxim juice out you know like yes just
amazing okay what let's just make
anyways that's a that's gonna check out
what the [ __ ] going on here yeah how
do you park get sued what
ok ok as always a time ok so we're
looking for this rock edge okay I'm
gonna [ __ ] it I'll say before I get like
dick sucked out here he not only times I
walk through there will nothing i'm like
deck sucks ah to any time sometimes i'm
just not [ __ ] ready for it though
that's when you're like tired and it's
just not fun ok i just watch out kids
watch up [ __ ] enemy a bad isn't there
oh my god
I counters may try to hit miss [ __ ] now
ok
and I supposed to be [ __ ] up here who
the [ __ ] is that ok it's not my business
of [ __ ] yeah it's in it good good good
ok don't see any up ahead oh thank you
sir I guns
I think it's up here attention
Cheryl I got one hour left that's okay
you know yes yes that's counting you
know [ __ ] ironic okay I need a good
name oh here we get some guns here um
sure and I like why not like I'm
friendly itself throne after right not
now that was insanely violent okay okay
[ __ ] did i get x pay for that because it
feels like i did it yeah it sounds
pretty nice day I guess I
yeah [ __ ] fart I gotta walk in this
game 10 miles are 10 miles like what the
[ __ ] not this is gonna mean I get a game
are you [ __ ] I was there and he says
ah yes yes Wow else there
okay I got operates yeah autistic
indivisible wall
okay I got to go up somehow [ __ ] am I
gonna do that yes I just keep going in a
circle so I got higher and higher you
know there we go
mm-hmm is that the crash see how much a
[ __ ] everywhere great [ __ ] varmint
sailing map all right i got like my sex
right here nice and collapse so now that
one though okay tax ID on here
Tony if I were higher [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is this place
now ok what we rushed